سفاره روسيا لدى المانيا تصف قرار برلين
بتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات اليوبارد بالخطير
للغايه وان هذه الخطوه ستنقل الصراع الى
مستوى جديد من المواجهه اما سفاره روسيا
لدى الولايات المتحده فتتحدث عن ان تزويد
واشنطن لكيف بالدبابات الامريكيه هو
بمثابه عمليه استفزاز جديده لموسكو خارجيه
البلاد ترى في عمليه تزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات الالمانيه جزء من مخطط مسبق
لشني حرب على روسيا اما الكرملين فصرح على
لساني المتحدث الرسمي باسمه متربيسكو ان
الدبابات الغربيه ستصبح رمضان وستحترق مثل
غيرها لكن الفرقه الوحيد انها باهضه الثمن
وان دافعي الضرائب الاوروبيين كما سماهم
سيقعوا على عاتقهم في نهايه المطاف دفع
قيمته هذه الخسائر
ان يصنع
الفعل
في العمليه العسكريه
الدبابات يجب ان لا يكون محددا علينا
لاستمرار والنتائج ستظهر
المعركه حاسمه ولا مجالا لاي خطه اخرى